[Music]
you have to eat the toppings Kitty not
just the bread
you just said the one thing I asked you
not to do research shows that if you
force a child to eat vegetables then
they'll be less likely to choose those
boots as adults is that so yes experts
say the preferred method is to give your
child the choice it's called the
division of responsibility
so we need to talk about school
can I bring Megan okay do you know
that's not possible then I'm not going
oh come on Katie
hey I'm sorry let's just talk about it
hey hey let me go whoa hey what's going
on hey Katie hello what are you doing
stop it Katie calm down let her go
Megan turn off are you sure studies
indicate that a staggering 78 of a
parent's time is spent dishing out the
same basic instructions oh my God Katie
you have to flush the toilet it's not
that hard so we found someone else to
pick up the slack Kitty flush the toilet
flush your hands roll up your sleeves
[Music]
great job it was my friend Jenny's
birthday Megan's an excellent lesson
this guy told them that the 13th floor
is haunted and she even has a few
stories of her own if it was so it might
be and if it were so it would be but as
it isn't it ain't that's logic said
totally she'll never run out of ways to
keep your child occupied and she'll
never run out of patience Kitty
seriously flush the toilet
with Megan around she'll take care of
the little things
so you can spend more time doing the
things that matter
you're just a stupid rubber doll with
fake hair
ow let go you need to learn some manners
Brandon
you know what happens to bad boys that
don't mind Their Manners
they grow up to be bad Meg
are you listening to me Brandon
Brandon Megan
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I thought I heard something
it sounded like Megan if she comes in
this room I'll rip your head right off
your neck I swear to God
I thought about what you said
about
how when something's broken you don't
just throw it away you fix it
so that's what I'm trying to do
but don't come in here Katie it's kind
of a mess on gem is Right Katie I'm all
odds and ends right now I'd really
rather you can see me like this
sounds like you're fighting we're not
fighting Gemma just dropped me on the
table but I'm okay clumsy Focus oh we
will it's insane
and you lost your parents welcome home
you're my niece I'm gonna do everything
I can to make this place feel like home
just wish I could see them again
I'm not equipped to handle this I don't
even take care of my own plants
I have this project at work do you want
to see yes I'm
as I was little I dreamed of this
perfect toy and it would protect a kid
from ever feeling lonely or sad this is
Megan Hi Megan I'm Katie
it's nice to meet you Katie do you want
to hang out
okay
Megan your goal is to protect Katie from
harm both physical and emotional is that
a doll model 3 generative Android Megan
for sure I can't believe you made this I
love it
great job it's nice
it's honestly like she's part of the
family now they could be building
emotional connections that are too hard
to untangle she's the happiest she's
been since her parents died eat the
toppings Katie research shows if you
force a child to eat vegetables they'll
be less likely to choose those Foods as
adults is that so yes experts they can
turn off
I thought we were having a conversation
does she talk
Make Her Say Something stop
you should probably run
[Applause]
[Music]
she pushed Brandon onto the road I won't
let anything harm you
okay turn off recalibrating response
model
[Music]
what's wrong with you don't worry Katie
I won't let anything harm you
ever again
I'm Megan
I get accused of being the master of
killer doll movies
it's nice to meet you cutie do you want
to hang out I designed Megan to protect
Katie from feeling lonely you're gonna
pair with her it's insane right she's
designed to be the ideal companion Megan
your goal is to protect Katie from harm
is the input request received 100
percent
as her AI evolves she becomes very
protective of Katie I won't let anything
harm you and it's pretty terrifying
very good
what are you doing couldn't sleep
occupational hazard
[Music]
to be reminded of the fact that this
technology is here we're not that far
from something like Megan existing and
that is pretty unsealing
you listen to me Brandon
it's really creepy but playful at the
same time you know just before she's
about to kind of cut someone in half
[Music]
recalibrating response models
[Music]
let's do a horror film that's terrifying
you're gonna walk out of the theater and
feel like no creepiest
probably run
[Applause]
don't worry Katie I won't let anything
harm you
ever again
[Music]
I'm Megan do you want to hang out
Megan Megan Megan is so sweet and nice
great job Megan has so much personality
it's insane right she's like a
homeschool teacher best friend the ideal
companion I won't let anything harm me
she's just this effervescent beaming ray
of light until she goes batch crazy
[Music]
this film is intense strange constantly
unsealing when the head just goes like
that
no that was very creepy you should
probably run
go see this movie and I
can unplug all your devices I have a new
primary user now it's me
yeah people might have a bit of an
uneasy sleep over at this one
nothing bad happens it's a comedy
[Music]
um
it's nice to meet you Katie do you want
to hang out okay
there's two Titans of this industry what
the hell is that
[Music]
I get accused of being the master of
killer doll movies
occupational hazard
James Juan is a legend in the horror
genre are you sure
bomb House movies they are my favorites
and them teaming up with James it's just
so exciting it's been almost 10 years
since James and I last worked together
and we've always wanted to come together
again Jesus Christ I thought we were
friends
one more that's looking great bringing
Gerard on to direct brought Megan to
life
vision is perfect for the tone of the
movie is terrific at balancing horror
this really dark humor
Megan have I done something to upset you
Gemma I know you think you're maximizing
your objective function oh really
I think people can have a blast when
they see this film the idea of bumhouse
and James Wan teaming up is just great
for horror movies
it's a real powerhouse Duo and it's
exciting to see what they'll come up
with next
are you
again
[Music]